Welcome to my talk on Async and streaming
JavaScript, are we doing it wrong.
Of course the answer is always going to be
yes, otherwise why am I standing on stage
here, what better picture than to know John
McCarthy telling us we're exactly doing programming
wrong.
So before I get started I actually want to
thank the organizers very much, because, of
course, this is my first time speaking here,
but I've been coming here since 2010 and without
a conference such as this things like no J
S on windows might not have happened or might
not have happened as quickly as it did.
It's with this very conference that it's really
amazing stuff to me.
So, what I'm talking about Async or Async
or vent‑based programs, I think to myself,
I thought I had a problem, I know, I'll solve
it with call backs and events.
Now have I problems, two I, yeah ...
crap! Yeah.
The con currency bugs, been bugging me since
I started doing JavaScript.
What this talk will not be it will not be
a Monad tutorial, no mention of category theory,
it doesn't require you to know much about
functional programming to really get started.
To learning new abstractions for asink nows
programming.
So,‑‑ Asyncous programming, no they're
not like Burritos or any other way you can
think of to describe Monads.
I'm a software engineer, self described Open
Sourcerer, you can find me on Twitter and
GitHub, using the same tag, I'm fairly unoriginal
that way.
And I work for this small start up out of
the Seattle Washington area.
I don't know if you've heard of them they're
called Microsoft.
And I like to think of myself as putting a
little bit of metal back in Microsoft.
Add Umlauds to anything automatically turns
it into metal.
I worked on a project called the reactive
extensions, I've been working on this since
120, the idea behind the reactive extensions
is really to create a nice programming language
agnostic way of dealing with Asyncous programming,
and I am an Rx pusher.
Now, really what I want to get through first
is that I want some quotes that will help
us in our learnings today.
The first one is to be conscious that you
are ignorant is a step towards knowledge.
The next one is ignorance never settles a
question.
And the third one is the best way to become
acquainted with a subject is to write a book
about it.
Or in my case, get up here and give a talk
And this was given by the Prime Minister of
the UK back in the 19th century.
So, let's just face it, asynchronous programming
as we know it today is annoying, because by
themselves you have every library and every
certain thing doing it's own thing, whether
it's call backs and promises doing one thing
where it's yielding a single value verse events
where there's dealing with multiple values
so each concept is covering it's own little
piece of the story, not the whole piece.
So just to kind of give you an example here,
you'd certainly wouldn't call a promise on
an event that you expect for more than one
of just as you wouldn't, you wouldn't normally
need a collection to describe a single value.
But, even more than that, how about if I want
to make a web request and then combine that
with getting the key press event so that I
can send my data over to that and then we
need to make sure that we're not overloading
the server.
How do we think about that when we're just
talked about promises, call backs, timers,
etc., how do we deal with that.
Is there a better way that we can think about
asynchronous and event‑based programming?
Well, we had a very forward thinking president
in the United States who the early '60s came
to this very city and said.
ch Eii Berliner, we also said we chose to
solve asynchronous programming not because
it's easy but because they're hard‑‑
citation needed‑‑ damn it Wikipedia.
So call back hell is very much a real thing.
So, when you're dealing with call back hell
you've got nested function after nested function
where you're trying to accomplish something
Lynn I can't recallly, so for example‑‑
linearly.
So for here, I might want to play a movie,
what that entails is making sure that the
players initialized that I'm authorized to
do so, then when I'm done it authorizes me
with a movie ticket.
And what you end up with a cow's head.
All your code all it looks like is just a
cow's head at that point, somewhere the logic
gets lost.
And it's se evil.
So I don't know about you, when ever I write
code like that, this usually happens.
And it's not easy to recover from getting
bush burned like that.
And just as well, event‑based programming
is just as annoying, say for example we want
to create a drag event, a custom kind of event
that we do on our own, so what we would need
for that, we would need to say whether the
mouse is down or not have some stay test to
where the mouse is.
Then in the mouse down we would have to say,
okay, spouse down, here's with we started,
mouse move, we go, okay, mouse is down, let's
do some calculations and on a mouse up, we
say, everything's done, we're good to go.
And we have to, of course, not only add the
event listeners, but we also have to remove
them as well.
And that gets pretty darn annoying.
And so when you're dealing with that much
state, once again you're juggling and you
just can't hold it.
Especially when you're just trying to do something
else‑‑ add something new to your program,
that's what you end up with.
So let's talk a little bit asynchronous programming
landscape, the landscape in general.
Two accessese siss, one to describe synchronous
and one to describe asynchronous behavior,
one to describe a single value and one to
say it's multiple.
For example, when you're dealing with a value
you call a function or you assign it a value,
that's a value, good.
An iterble is a collection so in JavaScript
we have arrays, we have maps, sets, arguments,
anything that's iterble here, and then we
can apply higher order operation such as map,
filter and for each.
But what about asynchronous single values,
we have call backs but we also have promises,
now promises are very interesting in the fact
that now instead of the call back function,
you have a first class object that you can
pass around the people that describes what
that value eventually will be.
And that's not something you can necessarily
do with a call back, I can't hand you a call
back and say this represents a value, doesn't
work that way.
And then what I'll put in the fourth quadrant
and final quadrant is observable, now observable
as you will see is asynchronous in it's very
nature so you can take the same stock data,
you can filter it, map it, and you can four
each it, no code changed at all in terms of
what you're coding on the client, non, nothing,
whatsoever.
That's very, very intentional about what we've
done with the observable design, so if you
know how to program against collections then
you know how to program against observables.
What I like to say, a lot of the times is
that your mouse is also a database, it's a
database of coordinates you'll get eventually
when the mouse moves, it should be as querible
as an iterative sequence is.
So, the thing that I like about these abstractions
is that they're first class.
And then what it means by first class is the
fact that I can pass one of these objects
whether it's an observable, or it's a promise
to a function and I can also return it from
a function.
And so what that gives us it gives us a lot
of little flexibility when it comes to querying
something or for testing for mocking whatever
else it is, it's really nice for us to do
that.
Now, promises, I'm sure you've heard a lot
about, I hear already, I've seen it mentioned
a good number of talks already.
Now promises are great because they're pretty
much in every single library that are out
there nowadays, and that have pretty much
the same behavior outside of jQuery, they
have pretty much the same behavior so you
can think about them pretty much the same,
asynchronous handled, and once you're done,
it's done, everyone gets the same answer,
so we can take the previous thing that we
talked about, the call back hell and distill
it down to the player initialized authorizing
the movie, if you're handling the log‑inner
report, playing the movie saying you're unauthorized.
No more trying to finish and detecting whether
this state is available or not.
But, there's some problems I have, at least,
when it comes to promises, promises don't
solve everything.
So, for example cancellation is not a part
of the contract for promises in ES 6.
Why? Because there are a good number of reasons
you want most people to fall into the happy
path and be pretty productive, but it's very
much the case when you deal with a lot of
things such as dealing with IO where cooperationlation
is a normal part of what do you and what about
situations with an auto complete that you
just don't care about the value that comes
back.
In this particular case here, how do I cancel
that again? I don't‑‑ I'm not really
interested in this anymore? I I don't know
so do I create a cancellation promise and
I sub class the regular promise? Do I mass
a cancellation token? Do I‑‑ or do I
just use a library like last from Donmick
Dencola, all of those are perfectly optionble
options.
When I talk about reactive programming, it's
a very kind of fuzz city definition just like
functional programming is.
Says functional programming, application of
functions, not helpful.
So what we're trying to do is trying to figure
out exactly what we could call reactive programming.
So, the dictionary says readily responds to
a stimulus, well isn't that just normal programming?
What else is interesting about it? Well, reacting
to events is certainly one thing that reactive
applications do, but they also react to load,
so the fact is that you can spin up more instances
to handle data, you can determine whether
you need to drop data and so forth.
You can react to failure, so if at any point
that you need to handle some errors and return
it from cache, you can certainly do that.
But, to me, most importantly is reacting to
your user.
The last thing you want to do is have your
JavaScript page be unresponsive to a particular
user.
And, what I'd like to say is, you know, the
reactive extension stuff that I've done has
played a little bit of a role, there's a lot
of hype, obviously around there with Gartner
and so forth with reactive programming, when
I talk about reactive programming here, I'm
just talking about observables, why don't
we take the previous example of that mouse
drag and kind of turn it inside out and turn
it in to an observable solution, what would
it look like? Well, if we had this first class
object of the mouse down, we can take that
and combine‑‑ and start to do a calculus
so flat map will basically it will take a
sequence and it will flatten it into a single
value or a single stream of values rather.
We can calculate the offset of where we started
for every mouse down.
Now, we can start to take the mouse moves
by once again using functional programming
things that we already know with using arrays,
and the array extras we can say take the mouse
move, which is also another first class object,
map it so we can design to give the left and
the top so the total differential between
the two.
Okay.
Pretty good.
So, the problem is we'll be going like this
and then forever it'll keep ongoing because
it never responds to the mouse up.
But we can fix that by saying take until mouse
up.
So mouse up, once again, a first class object,
we can say when ever this fires stop the sequence,
we're done.
And even holds a little bit more promise sufficient
it to say when you're dealing with promises.
So, what if we want to take some input as
it were, take the inputs value and then we're
going to call‑‑ make an auto complete
scenario here, what we want to do is we don't
want to overload the server because our Bandwidth
is time and money, quite honestly, so what
do we need to do to fix that, well, we have
things such as throttle,throttle or debounce
as most people know it where you can type,
type, type, stop for half a second and suddenly
it'll fire.
Excellent.
So, if‑‑ when we're thinking about observables,
we're thinking about once again back to the
access there, we have the observable and we
have the observable and the notion of acinous
or time based we can get the value (Asynchronous
did) we can call a service which might be
a promise only getting the last one.
So one of the biggest problem problems with
asynchronous programming is what? Is that
you are dealing with the fact that you could
get out of order responses and this fixes
and then you bind that to the UI and you're
good to go.
Even more complex things, I'm not going to
bother explaining all of this, even more complex
things such as poling for more updates that's
complicated by RX handles it just fine.
What we fled to know is everything's a stream.
It's a very zen like moment, you're like,
yes, I got this.
This is not to be confused with FRP, FRP is
a notion of continuous time, behaviors are
objects with a continuous piece of time, and
a continuous value, whereas events are different.
Events only have values when they fire.
And most of those‑‑ what it is not,
it is not just any old library that has map
filter and reduce on observables, so most
FRP libraries aren't.
So, what about generators.
So, I'm sure that a lot of people have seen
what generator cans do, and so yield suspends
the functiontion and resumes when you actually
get the value back, and a number of libraries
already support this.
Well, the library that I work on does it as
well, as well as Q Co you can say retry three
times here and you still get the benefit of
observables, yet you get a very linear imperative
style.
CSP, Eh, I'm okay, on it, it's interesting,
but a lot of people seem to love CAR.Async,
they seem to think that it's a good win.
Like I said, I'm not all that amused by it
because it makes error handling very manual,
it makes resource management very manual.
Not a far.
Asink await also is very worthwhile in terms
of discovering what's new in JavaScript.
So what we have is we have Async await which
has been approved for ES 7, at least the first
stage.
We can now take some animations and we can
start to await each one as it comes through.
That's pretty powerful.
So it makes it explicit that we're dealing
with an asin crow next so we don't have to
deal with function star and yield stuff, it
makes it very, very obvious.
Now let's QUICly talk about stream processing.
Now, when you near node, I don't know how
many people dealt with streams 1, but let's
face it, it was awful.
The pause didn't, data didn't start meetly,
can't consume a number of bytes, everything
was just shoved at you.
Pause and resume was impossible.
It was basically this (Laughing) so, then
we got streams 2 which land in the 0.9 and
eventually the stable 0.10, supported object
mode, instant now and everything was good,
then we got readable/writable classes, which
was good, duplex and pass throughs and streams
33 and a third when ever they decide to land
and V 0.12 (Giggles) I'm sure that'll solve
everything too.
Cork, uncork pretty cool stuff in terms of
being able to deal with mass data rights.
Still, to me, it's too employment Kateed.
So, the whatWG streams, what they're trying
to do is trying to standardize a lot of this
for lower level APIs for what's going into
the browsers, so come nick, who is here‑‑
Domnik is here, he's working on that and it's
working on lower level IO, and cast which
means one person reads, one person writes
(Uniany cast) can we take and generalize what
we're trying to do here into a more general
kind of thing where we're talking about like
observables.
And the answer is yes, and the answer, unfortunately
is dart.
Dart is doing those kind of things where asynchronous
programming they do with futures and streams
automatically, so futures, great, streams,
unify.O and vents together.
So literally, your Oparin (Unify I/O) you
can use the same API throughout all of them.
Now reactive streams is an effort that's going
on because a lot of people in the observable
world say, well you can't do back pressure,
can you? Because I mean come on you deal with
a lot of people handling your data, we can't
possibly‑‑ we can't possibly know how
to deal with this.
You know, a node and others have it very easy
where you have one coming in, one going out
that if you kind of crimp the hose, that's
fine, no big deal.
But when you're dealing with a multi‑cast
situation, it kind of is a big deal.
With observables we have notions of back pressure,
they could be lassi, possible, sampling throttling,
they could be lossless, so I could pauseble
buffer, pause and resume, or control, so for
example here, I can take my chatty observable,
pauseble buffer it, then pause and resume,
and anything that happened in between the
pause and resume I still get.
And just as well while we're building it into
the very core part each subscription will
be able to say I want to request "N" number
of items, so once again back pressure is something
that we have definitely under our belt.
Now where do we go from here? I think there's
actually a lot of places we can go because
of the fact that Async away‑‑ all these
things are pushing the envelope.
And that's really cool thing, but what if
we could go even further? So in: Seven Jafar
Husain a member of the ES 39 communication
committee proposed Async generators in which
we could take that very same mouse/drag and
put it into the for/on kind of syntax so you
could say let mouse donee down on element
mouse down, that first class object, document.mouse
move, first class object, taken till document.mouse
ups, yield the mouse move.
Good.
So that to me is very, very interesting and
I think there are a lot of places that we
can go with these kinds of approaches.
So ...
I will be upstairs if anyone has any questions
or if anyone wants an RX sticker come find
me, I want to thank you very much for your
time (Applause).